we begin our Hannity watch on huge
massive political hypocrisy tonight now
Democrats you watch them closely people
on the Left they claim to have a
monopoly of compassion conservatives are
cold-hearted they're even selfish and
greedy because they want low taxes and
less government bureaucracy they say
we're mean-spirited wanting to curtail
entitlements not true I don't know
Republicans that want to get rid of
Social Security or Medicare if that's
one of those campaign lies or if you
don't trust their health care system
hasn't worked out well Democrats are
always generous but with other people's
money but when it now comes to what is a
real life-or-death crisis at our
southern border they're nowhere to be
found in fact the Democrats the radical
left new talking point is to call what
is death and destruction and chaos
caused by unsecure borders nothing more
than a manufactured crisis watch this
president Trump must stop holding the
American people hostage but to stop
manufacturing a crisis this president
just used the backdrop of The Oval
Office to manufacture a crisis folks the
president has manufactured one heck of a
political crisis for himself
manufacturing a national security crisis
you will hear you're gonna say is that
this is a manufactured crisis it's not a
national security crisis the big scam of
the hole address was that there's a
crisis there's not a crisis the notion
that we have a crisis there security
crisis is absolute nonsense it remains
the Seinfeld shutdown all about and
saying all about nothing what happens
when there was a real crisis when there
was a real emergency does he take to the
airwaves do we give him the airwaves do
we believe him there is not a crisis at
the border
it's a manufactured crisis for the
president to get a political win he's
determined to convince you there is a
crisis at the border even though and
intelligence official tells CNN quote no
one is saying this is a crisis except
then my first thing you got to notice is
do you notice how the hate Trump
Democrats and the hate Trump media that
they speak in one voice that one talking
point now too
we're gonna do something as we promised
you at the beginning of the year you
will not see on any other Network and
we're going to show you what our real
victims of the crisis at our southern
border look at the side of your screen
take a look there
man women husbands wives children
parents those are all human beings that
have been killed because we have
unsecure southern border that's that's
those are real names that includes
police officer Ronald Singh he was
gunned down by that illegal immigrant
just after Christmas an officer's Singh
leaving behind a wife and a five month
old baby boy who will never know his
father Democrats are the are you really
prepared the media Democratic Party
liberals are you gonna look in this
man's family's face and tell them that
this death is a manufactured crisis
weirder of your hearts gone and earlier
this week we interviewed the parents of
this young man Pierce Corcoran and he
was killed by a suspected illegal
immigrant driving on the wrong side of
the highway without a license without
insurance in the country 14 years a
Democrats going to call the Corcoran's
and tell them what happened to their son
is a manufactured crisis what about Josh
Wilkerson or Dominic Durden or sergeant
Brandon Mendoza or Jamil Shah or grant
Rana Berger and I can keep going just
keep watching the names on the side of
your screen tonight the Democrats really
want you to believe this is some grand
conspiracy a manufactured crisis now we
do have angel parents those who have
lost their children because of open
borders they are speaking out tonight
and they have done so many times in the
past and they are reminding some of
America's politicians and their best
friends in the media that this is not a
political game for them this is a crisis
a clear and present danger real
Americans losing real lives needlessly
and real family suffering if you might
say a word permanent separation take a
look when you hear Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi last night saying that the
president has manufactured a crisis to
sell this wall what's your message to
those top Democrats it may seem
manufactured to them because they're
sitting safely behind
but for those of us out in regular
America we are victims we are prone to
the victimization of illegal aliens in
crime I'm just wondering how many of
these people have had their sons
daughters wives or husbands life snuffed
out by one of these illegal aliens I'm
just wondering if Nancy Pelosi had one
of her children our grandchildren
assaulted in the same way that my son
was assassinated if she would speak the
same way no I bet the reporter what 12
13 times now last time I was down with
Governor Perry then governor at the time
sat in a security briefing six hundred
and forty two thousand crimes committed
against Texans alone in a seven year
period in just the past two years alone
four thousand criminal aliens have been
arrested for homicide in fact over the
past two decades criminal immigrants
have been responsible for tens of
thousands of murders now to these
families our fellow Americans that
crisis is always present their lives
have been devastated forever altered
their loved ones murdered and yet hate
Trump Democrats hate Trump talking point
media people dare to suggest that this
is a manufactured crisis really we're
talking about an all-too-common
occurrence it should never happen
law-abiding men and women killed by
illegal immigrants that don't respect
our laws or sovereignty or borders they
shouldn't be here at all now if we
secure the borders lives are going to be
saved people will be protected there
won't be permanent separation as in the
cases we're telling you about now many
of these cases those responsible even in
long criminal track record some had
previously been deported all gaining
access because our southern border is
wide open and sadly this is only one
aspect of the crisis at our southern
border over the past two years 30,000
criminal aliens arrested for sex crimes
over a hundred thousand for violent
assaults in 2018 800 gang members
apprehended at our southern border
that's a 50 percent increase over the
previous year yes last year we also saw
one hundred and a 22 percent increase in
fenton all being smuggled across the
southern border you know fentanyl that's
the drug that's killing Americans every
single day in this country Fenton all
the deadly substance often mixed with
heroin
remember heroin 90% of that smuggled
across our southern border and keep in
mind that every seven days 300 Americans
will die from a heroin overdose that
death toll is equal to the number of
American troops that were killed every
week in Vietnam during 1968 that was the
deadliest year of that war so is that a
manufactured crisis last year 17,000
individuals with criminal records
apprehended trying to cross the border
60,000 inadmissible or illegal
immigrants turned away from our borders
every single month and over the last few
weeks 20,000 children smuggled or
traffic into the United States this is
not a manufactured crisis or a talking
point those children matter
those women matter those Americans being
killed by addiction matter we talk about
the opioid epidemic in the country all
the time this is a big part of it and so
do the human beings by the way on the
other side of the border totally
understand the 98% that want a better
life for themselves their family their
children their grandchildren but one out
of every three migrant women who make
that dangerous trip try to get into the
United States hoping for a better life
they're sexually assaulted and seven and
ten migrants have reported being victims
of violence during that trek it's an
arduous journey and an average of 50
children each day require emergency
medical care after they arrive at the
southern border and you have thousands
of illegal immigrants they have died
trying to cross unfamiliar deserts in
unsecured regions of our border and
don't forget about the risks that are
posed to our national security
unvetted illegal immigrants from all
over the world use our unsecured
southern border in order to gain access
to the United States Sarah Carter
recently took a trip to the border
actually interviewed two individuals
there from Bangladesh take a look the
donators get by east what country
Bangladesh Bangladesh how long have you
been walking
three months please put your hands down
hands down don't worry don't worry I'm
I'm a journalist three months yeah from
Bangladesh through Mexico to the United
States do you know where you're at right
now no who brought you here
who who helped you over Mexico Mexico
isn't I don't know what was the first
country you came after Bangladesh Dubai
Brazil and then through Central America
and then up here to the United States
and you have the median Democrats
telling you this is a manufactured
crisis we're gonna have more from Sara's
trip to the border coming up you're
definitely gonna want to see what she
has discovered also last night in order
to address many of these issues the
president delivered a powerful address
unveiled a plan to fix this crisis but
the left their friends there willing
accomplices in the media don't seem to
care look at late night Seth Meyers
actually joking about the devastation at
our southern border tweeting is the Oval
Office SVU and socialist congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio Cortez even calling
for ice to be abolished
take a look women and children on that
border that are trying to seek refuge
and seek opportunity in the United
States of America with nothing but a
shirt on their backs are acting more
American than any person who seeks to
keep them out a child died in ice
custody the president should not be
asking for more money to an agency that
has systematically violated Human Rights
the president should be really defending
why we are funding such an agency at all
because right now what we are seeing is
death right now what we are seeing is
the violation of Human Rights these
children and these families are being
held in what are called yella das which
are basically freezing boxes that no
person should be maintained in this is
systemic it is wrong and it is
anti-american Wow
that's NBC reporting because
cortes not the only Democrat living in
this fantasy world yesterday during an
extremely bizarre joint speech worthy of
a Saturday Night Live open skit at a
shared podium speaker Pelosi Senate
Minority Leader Chuckie Schumer
literally they were scowling as they
offered zero solutions to the crisis and
they started pushing the manufactured
crisis line is this the liberal
compassion that they lecture us about
all the time
did they not care about human beings on
both sides of the border longtime
Democratic strategist even James
Carville he made a joke about Schumer's
forced Democratic rebuttal dead-on
accurate take a look I don't think they
wanted to do it I don't think they
should have done it and I guarantee at
the staff meeting tomorrow morning
somebody is going to get you know and
shoot out pretty good the only good
thing about it it didn't matter they
could have given to Gettysburg Address
and it wasn't about it it didn't he
didn't want to be I've been more excited
about colonoscopies and he wasn't in his
speech tonight funny and true and
accurate but not really a laughing
matter when you talk about the issue you
know over the course of my career thirty
years in radio my 23rd year here at Fox
I have interviewed way too many angel
moms dads brothers and sisters over the
years people that lost children a pain
that most never recover from and this is
the pain of which the president now is
looking to solve a problem opening a
door to the White House urging lawmakers
from both sides of both parties to come
and negotiate but during today's meeting
Democrats again they're not interested
at all for them political optics Trump's
all take a look I want to turn the floor
over the president said to Speaker
Pelosi and Schumer gee again to argue
whether we even have a crisis or whether
facts are true
turn to Schumer again who said we just
have to open the government up president
then turn to the speaker that politely
asked her okay Nancy if we open the
government up in 30 days
could we have border security she raised
her hand and said no not at all the
president calmly said I guess you're
still not wanting to deal with the
problem the president wants to solve
this problem that's why he continues to
bring us down that's why he's put offers
on the table not once had the Democrats
offered anything back and the way they
had displayed and their behavior is
embarrassing to me
in 2006 remember Democrats had a very
different perception and did very
different ideas and they and Republicans
came together to fund a partial border
wall they supported it then the secure
Fence Act allowed over fifty billion
dollars over the next two decades to
construct and maintain hundreds of miles
of new barriers sixty-four Democrats in
the House voted in favor of the bill in
the Senate passed with overwhelming
support both parties including Chuckie
Schumer and then Senator Hillary Clinton
and California senators boxer and
Feinstein and even Barack Obama voted to
fund the wall now campus reform recently
asked college students to react to
quotes from several top Democrats who
once supported a border wall they did it
with a twist take a look what's your
thought on his push for this wall
I am NOT a fan everyone has a shared
reaction to this it's absolutely
horrendous I really don't see a need for
we should spend money to build a barrier
to prevent illegal immigrants from
coming in another quote we simply cannot
allow people to pour into the u.s.
undetected undocumented and unchecked
quote illegal immigration is wrong plain
and simple until the American people are
convinced we will stop future flows of
illegal immigration will make no
progress when you hear quotes like that
what's your reaction to them it's
divisive I think America is a land of
opportunity place for inclusion I just
really think it's a kind of hateful
speech in general it's a negative
message what if I told you these were
from Chuck Schumer Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton how about that Oh Trump
says that it's bad Democrats say it it's
good now Trump's president now the wall
two Democrats are suddenly immoral
actually Democrats what they're doing is
playing politics and risking in the
process the lives of American citizens
just because they don't like Donald
Trump who wants to solve a problem and
yet the solution they once supported is
effective we know the wall works after
the completion of the wall south to San
Diego the illegal traffic dropped by
approximately 92% the wall in El Paso
Texas resulted in a significant drop as
it did walls in Tucson in Yuma Arizona
where they extended one wall from five
miles to 65 miles
it drops 95 percent the president is now
requesting one tenth of one percent of
our federal budget to build more
strategic barriers he's also requesting
increased Border Patrol and ice
personnel and an increase in detention
capacity and humanitarian resources and
counter smuggling tools along with other
important technology this is not a
radical plan it's a plan to keep
Americans safe it addresses what is an
urgent serious crisis so let me say I
understand by the way the concerns 25
percent partial government shutdown our
furloughed workers furloughed look I've
been there in my life living paycheck to
paycheck it's not fun they will and
should and deserve to recoup all of
their money
while they're not working they deserve
it and this is though for others life
and death literally preventable death
which makes this all the more
frustrating officer Singh is gone
forever
the Cochran's will never see their son
Pierce again the families of the people
you see on the right of your screen
throughout the night tonight they
deserve better these deaths are not
manufactured this is not a manufactured
crisis and the Democrats and their
allies in the media they're talking
point frankly is cold heartless it's a
lie and frankly a slap in the face to
every angel mom and dad and family
member in this country that have lost
loved ones as a result of open borders
and illegal immigration or every family
that's lost a loved one from a heroin
overdose or from other drugs smuggled
over the are wide open borders the
clashes with Border Patrol agents rocks
bottles thrown chaos destruction they
also that's not manufactured that's real
Democrats remember that it wasn't a
manufactured crisis because they were
politically bludgeoning Trump over the
family separation issue something that
he eventually stopped that had happened
in the two previous administrations it
wasn't a manufactured crisis for
Democrats or the media when they were
bludgeoning our brave border patrol
officers who had to use tear gas after
they were being pelted with rocks and
models remember the left accused them of
gassing children so a pelosi schumer the
rest of the democratic party in the
media want to stay on manufactured
crisis and allow this to continue and
play a political game the president he
will have the full authority and power
to declare a national emergency and
tackle this head-on with or without
congressional funding approval or he
could use the Defense Department this is
about protecting our homeland but first
it's up to you look at the number on
your screen
you might want to call ask your member
of Congress of the Senate to hold the
line this is too important
202 two to four 3121